the prosecution in derrick shovin's
murder trial is strongly attacking the
defense argument
that the fired police officer is not
what killed george floyd
prosecutors called three medical experts
to lay out exactly what they say led to
floyd's death in minneapolis and as
jamie yukis reports
all of them dismissed the defense theory
of a drug overdose
we do have to warn you that this
testimony may be hard to listen to
the healthy person subjected to what mr
floyd was subjected to would have died
dr martin tobin who has written what is
considered the bible of textbooks on
lung function
testified that george floyd died due to
the weight on his neck and back
leaving no room for his lungs to expand
half of his body weight
plus half his gear weight is coming down
that's 91.5 pounds is coming down
directly on mr floyd's neck the cause of
death
is a low level of oxygen that caused the
brain
damage and caused the heart to stop in a
video so disturbing we are not airing it
tobin showed in slow motion floyd taking
his last breath
when he last take a breath the knee
remains on the neck
for another three minutes and 27 seconds
after there's no
pulse the knee remains on the neck for
another
two minutes and 44 seconds the defense
argues that the drugs and floyd system
as well as his underlying health
conditions led to his death
but tobin was clear throughout if
somebody
is suffering from a fentanyl overdose
you would see a depression in the
respiratory system
did you see any depression in mr floyd's
ability to breathe whatsoever before he
went unconscious
no absolutely not thursday's last
witness dr william smock
backed up dr tobin's assessment mr floyd
died from positional asphyxia
which is a fancy way of saying he died
because he had no oxygen left in his
body
did you consider other possibilities as
causes
that you evaluated and dismissed is
unlikely absolutely
joe tamborino is a minnesota criminal
defense attorney who is not affiliated
with the case
if you were defending derek chovin would
you tell him to testify
at this point i would tell him to
testify because there's been such
damning information that's gone in
really what why not
the city's chief medical examiner is
expected to testify today
he ruled floyd's death as a homicide and
the cause as cardiac arrest
complicated by restraint and neck
compression
that means the defense can make a case
that chauvin complicated floyd's death
but did not actually cause it anthony
jamie thank you